good morning Millennials happy Monday
good morning Millennials how is everyone
doing on this spritely bright and
exciting Monday morning said nobody ever
I'm not doing well [ __ ] oh you're not
like no it was a amazingly fun weekend
amazingly but missed fun automatically
comes a level of Treacher that is
unavoidable and I'm feeling the
consequences when there's something
funny sharing that when I spent the week
in the Hamptons with Ben's family like I
was just talking you know as I do and I
said treacherous just like cuz it's a
word and Ben's dad was like hysterically
I think it's like that's such a funny
word like a unique way to use it and
like I just don't think of it as like a
it's like a serious word you know I know
and he's like that's just a hilarious
word and I was like it is it's a
hilarious word we also do use it a
little bit improperly like we sometimes
we the way that we're using it is right
but a lot of the times we say
treacherous also means like a betrayal
like or like I'm too dangerous yeah but
we mean it to mean like sweaty and like
lots of one like I'm struggling because
treacherous those aren't that's not the
case okay I heard that dictionary.com is
going to be adding another definition to
treacherous because of the toaster
because they're speaking of treacherous
you and I had an important business
meeting last night and we didn't we
didn't include treacherous oh yes that
we have to do okay we had an important
business and honestly I know everyone
has been up in arms about merch and like
we are working on it and you know if we
wanted to put out like t-shirts and hats
we could have done that like months ago
we are making stylized
like this is a lifestyle I it is like
it's really cute stuff and it's not just
like [ __ ] with our logo on it like it's
meaningful and it's gonna take a while
but like it's gonna be good and we're
trying to keep the prices low so like
bear with us and stop complaining please
thank you so we had a great weekend yeah
a great weekend what a like it all came
together so quickly on Friday when we
were sitting here I was undecided our
plan still hadn't come to fruition I was
going down the shore with my friends you
were thinking I'll go to Atlantic City
we were saying 20 minutes from Atlantic
City so we were like we'll come to the
big city if you guys do wind up there
right which they did and it was just so
crazy lit it was so lit like basically
we've been open to Atlantic City for
years uh-huh but I would say maybe five
years ago like after Hurricane sandy
they couldn't really recover and like it
was just like a lot of hotels went out
of business and like it was super like
sad me and Ben still went like once a
year
but we would just go to the Borgata and
stay inside the whole time it wasn't we
weren't going to a city we were just
going to hotel and there's like this big
resort with like lots of restaurants but
now that they have legalized sports
gambling the city has been a green
invigorated and the economy is like
turned around so like there are a bunch
of new hotels there's a Hard Rock and
there's the Ocean Resort they reopened
rebel which is where we spent the
weekend it's just hilarious because we
went to rebel like right before it
closed its last weekend open and it's
nothing has changed it's like they shut
the doors and they just reopen them five
years later with a new name and everyone
just walked right in and it's like a
mini Vegas wannabe they yes we went to
the HQ day party where Shaq was
deejaying you guys I have a bunch of
thoughts on Chinese and Shaq is the
biggest DJ in the world technically he
is not good well here's the thing I feel
like when celebrities become DJs they
actually just like grab the mic and
scream stuff and then if someone else
mixing the music but Jack had the
opposite like he I think he really wants
to become like a good DJ and Atlantic
City is a perfect jumping-off point for
him but he had this height man whose
microphone was a so loud it was
literally ringing in my ears and be like
wasn't good at it and see like was
singing like on the mic like that's not
what your job is you're just supposed to
be like yeah yeah like every 10 seconds
yeah he was so annoying that like I
wanted to kill him and like as a DJ yes
Shaq could definitely use some work but
I think that this Atlantic City is like
a perfect place for him to start it'll
be in Vegas in two years and he'll be
great no but like I just feel like being
a DJ really like yes maybe the mixing
isn't so easy but the premise is pretty
simple play music people want to dance
too and then change the song when the
good part of the first song is over not
right before it's gonna happen like
right that happened a lot like it was
about to hit like a great part in a song
and like he just went to a new song he
didn't even have that problem because he
didn't play any good song so there was
no song I was in our brand of music and
but it wasn't if it's not our brand and
we listen to the radio and we're women
of the world like it's not popular music
I don't want to dance to it in the club
on a Saturday when I'm turning up and
check your turning me down like I was
way too turned up for the level of shock
that level that check was that
however the
so Larry DJ before took over after and
after he did a great great job that
finally we were able to let loose a
little bit but he was six o'clock and we
had to go he was the in-house DJ for
fridge because he also was at the club
later that night he's great DJ Hoke I
don't know
Tok I don't know oh my god he was so
good at the club later that night and
then a track came on playing his crap
Ola yeah like stinker and a truck gave
me a dirty look in my Instagram story
did you see that like you should have
given him one right back for every ten
songs he played one was a hit like it
was just so up and down but the night
was so much fun the weekend was amazing
Ben won money thank God I lost like $150
I lost $100 but I brought someone I
brought way more money with me like
prepared to lose it so like technically
I won because I came home with a decent
amount of money but I brought it with me
whatever technicality I understand um
but actually something hilarious is we
had lunch you weren't there I was with
Olivia and Zach and we were like asking
for straws and like Atlantic City it's
just like eco-friendly and they don't
have straws and it was like such torture
but then we got it's like this
discussion about straws I'm like
honestly me in bed and like had this
moment where like we figured something
out like no one's talking about this one
thing about straws ready so you're just
like talking about like why they're bad
and like how he could fix them and Ben
was like Ben really like is an animal
lover and he was like I will give him my
straws because like it's so sad but the
turtles and I'm like totally I was
saying that we could definitely do more
to start but he's not wrong and then we
look at each other and we both have the
same thought at the same home and we're
like wait how are the straws getting
into the ocean like our landfills just
like dumping only plastic into like
we're like how is that possible so we
looked it up and you know how straws get
in the ocean like human error is voted
said like they'll blow from a garbage
can in ocean or people leave them on the
beach like yeah okay so we have to
completely get rid of straws when we
could just find a better way to dispose
of them do you know what I mean it's not
that straws existence is bad for turtles
it's the way we're disposing of them so
to eradicate them completely makes no
sense like just think for a minute if
straws were people there were human
beings what we don't like the way that
they they do one thing so we're gonna
kill them like it makes no sense I was
as my mind was like under this like
impression that like straws were evil
but straws themselves are not bad
hate to think say dispose of them as bad
so why don't we just do better as human
beings and not leave straws on beaches
or throw them overboard on a boat two
things to say that I found out recently
about straws one do you know who was
behind this implementation of no sharks
at Starbucks like who spearheaded this
and went to Starbucks like HQ Oh God and
begged for them together like no oh good
somewhere like we never talked about
Adrian Grenier loser loser taking credit
for like Starbucks big decision because
he went down there HQ to their
headquarters and made a big presentation
oh my god there's so many other worthy
causes like I can't even and I also
found out that Starbucks getting rid of
straws and making those new plastic
calves is more blessed and more plastic
than the stars themselves
so until what's not to stop you know the
wind from blowing a new a new the top of
a water bottle into the ocean like what
why straw
I'm sure they'll blow into the ocean but
it's not gonna get stuck in the turtles
nose oh like a fish it's the shape of
the right thing like a cup isn't isn't
gonna harm a turtle or anyone I can't
believe Adrian Grenier is behind this
behind this like mini Starbucks like
listen to him like totally doesn't work
anymore
I just think it's so crazy the Boris
draw it so unwarranted like literally at
the web we went to American [ __ ] for
dinner and I grabbed a busboy and I
whisper to him I'm like you got any
straws like drugs and he was like it we
got some in the back even though - no
Straub restaurant they had a couple for
like you know what they could get rid of
first it just stirs agreed because those
definitely get stuck in noses faster but
wood isn't bad no no but most stirrers
are like little straws oh oh yeah yeah
yeah oh my god useless you grab them at
a bar you think it's a straw but it's
like a tube and all of a sudden you have
like wrinkles here and yeah yeah and I
do need a sir but I'll take a wooden one
even though they're a little weird and
like like we were saying it's now like
it's a faux pas to like drink out of a
straw and like take a picture with a
straw and they just I'm here to say I
deep I care deeply about the environment
and I care deeply about the Turtles and
I do want to help them I just think a
like there are this is like such a big
move
like there's just so many worse things
than straws and to like I didn't realize
I thought like straws like we're bad
things like I mean I just can't believe
how like I was brainwashed by the media
like I'm extraor Evo but then I'm
thinking about I'm like are straws that
or just like the fact that they end up
in the ocean bad the fact that they end
up in the ocean how are they ending up
in the ocean humans like it's our fault
like let's just do better also if you
really want to use a straw and you
really care about the turtles and you
can't guarantee that you'll dispose of
it properly just cut it up before you
throw it away that way you won't get
stuck in the turtles now I melted I saw
that I'm like literally like every time
I got a straw at a restaurant and I get
like a new drink I like take the straw
and put in the old drink like you just
never know where your next shot is gonna
come from and they take them so quick
they do hopefully they're cutting them
up in the back yeah you guys I just
can't believe straws like wait I had I
had written a couple things down because
I went before we started the show I
don't know some housekeeping not really
I just wanted to get to my notes straws
done happy birthday to Allie Mohajir oh
such a great poster that we know his
name happy birthday he was in Vegas for
the weekend he said Vegas has completely
gotten rid of straws what and it's like
Vegas is so straws oh my god wait he's
birthday today yeah
happy birthday I can't oh my gosh I
can't believe I'm wearing I know like we
were celebrating you were a favorite
Vegas we were in satellite Vegas yes
said Vegas and I don't know if we have a
story about it but today's prime day her
story here are the fast five stories
that you need to know before you wake up
and take a bite out of your morning
toast so everyone has their hot takes on
prime day but I feel like this was one
that I felt like you guys needed to know
just so that you have all the
information going into the big day
Amazon Prime day check the competitors
Amazon has already started offering
deals even before the official start of
Pride Day but the discounts oh we aren't
always at the big bargains they appear
to be morons trampy deal editor for
mobile nations thrifter a size up
chatter oh [ __ ] that means it's real a
site dedicated to finding the best tech
tips and deals for consumers join
cheddar with some tips on how to weed
out the imposters you can look at a
website such as camel camel camel which
is one of our favorite favorite a teen
drifter you just enter in Amazon's items
SKU and it will show you all the
price tracking information so basically
Amazon like other retailers will
artificially jack up the price of
certain items before prime day making it
seem like the sale is way better than it
actually is so if you use one of these
trackers you'll see what the price was a
few weeks ago before they jacked it up
why do they do that because that's big
that's corporation for you oh my god
that is so upsetting what's the website
called where you can do that a camel
camel camel should we look something up
cuz I was gonna do something sure sure
okay
go to camel camel camel but let me get a
great value my privacy thank you let me
get you an item that's already in my
cart I was gonna buy a clock Oh keywords
okay hold on what about show you Amazon
echo yeah that's what I'm getting
second-generation echo doo-doo-doo-doo
okay I don't know how to use this
website actually this may be a bad
example cuz I think it's only sold on
Amazon right it says oh that's true
that's very true okay whatever go back
hold on I'm gonna go to their their
prime day deals they're gonna show me
their best deals ready they're only
showing me Amazon products come on shop
early access only showing me okay what
about here here are some the venturi
essential red wine aerator ooh that
sounds nice oh by the way people love
that it's the one when you don't have to
take the cork out to to pour wine and
then you get to keep it fresh it's
really good oh you don't use Amazon
price history currently it's at thirteen
ninety one the highest it was ever at
was 39.99 so good deal I don't even know
how this how would this one say word
that chart looks confusing honestly my
god you guys this is what we get for
doubting Amazon that feels like a great
deal honestly this is more work than
just buying an announcer like now I'm
wasting productivity I'm taking time out
of my money making and then I prepare
first it's exactly so you know what if I
just buy it without doing the research
I'll make more money being productive
somewhere else but that venturi Air
opener aerator thing Russell Dickerson
and Kayla use it all the time of their
Instagram stories and they like swear by
it
wait so now I have to get it it like it
like pumps air through air through the
cork and gets you could pour a glass of
wine without taking the cork out it's
crazy
that is so crazy I should get a except I
don't really drink wine at home anymore
and honestly after this weekend I'm not
drinking until Sunday no I'm not
drinking because I'm going to say no
some Thursday you're gonna be smoking
Mary Kay oh well that's true well I I
just I can't drink like near my shows
because like I really need a lot of
energy so Thursday I'm gonna be in st.
Louis it sold out so sorry
and I'm not adding a second job and then
I go to Denver Saturday where I'm going
to eat a net about no kidding I just
like I just feel like everyone in my
audience on Saturday is gonna be high on
marijuana well that'll be great because
then they'll laugh even hard I should
give out edibles I guess people walk in
just make sure that's within the legal
yeah we got like arrested and I'm not
adding a second Channel Denver either
but there are a couple tickets up
because it's my first theatre I've been
doing comedy clubs and now it's a
theater so when it's a theater do people
have to bide the seat or it's still like
it's James G a VIP I don't know when
that stops because what about in Boston
so what that's what I was just about to
say my Boston shows at the Wilbur
theater which is like an actual theater
where people like sing also and I
thought like maybe I'll be on StubHub
you know but it's still GA VIP
there's like certain sections sectioned
off for GA I'm crazy I know I don't know
when you get to the level of like buying
proceed that's when you make like a ton
of money interesante yeah and then
Sunday I get back and hopefully we'll
make it time in time for the toast with
concert I think I'm learning the Taylor
Swift concert Sunday now oh really yeah
Friday okay I'm just like so nervous
about it works better for just like
night that's why I wasn't into until
Sunday because I'm gonna drink at the
Taylor Swift concert yeah are you of
course I mean I get in Sunday like 5 so
I'm gonna need Ben to pick me up the
airport I'll just like change in the car
and go okay looking for Jack I don't
know why don't he's flying to work
that's a great idea I'm just always
thinking you're full of great ideas
okay next story our girl Kate Upton is
pregnant in Miami and I just I'm so
happy for her I feel like this was in
the toasters group before obviously and
you know I feel like if it wasn't if we
didn't have such a deep love for Kate
Upton like this wouldn't be a story
because all that there is to this news
is her Instagram caption and like
there's no additional news other than
she's hashtag pregnant in Miami with
Justin Verlander's baby we're assuming
she added him and she looks at me like
that means it says some yeah I guess it
means it says but you never know I love
the chili didn't make it like a big deal
do you know what I mean no and she
didn't like sell the story or like is
she
she like she's just a cool girl the
Train bellisario she's 100% pregnant we
announced it on the toast like Instagram
a couple maybe like two months ago and
everyone was giving me [ __ ] in the
comments like it's not it's not it's not
like saying that I'm fat shame here it's
like she doesn't even look pregnant I
just have it on amazing authority that
she is and then someone in the toasters
group did prenatal yoga with her and
confirmed that she is in fact pregnant
so I was right you were wrong grabs food
eat my ass I wonder if she's gonna be
going to prenatal yoga with Kate Upton
now Kate Upton is everything and more
I'm obsessed with her I'm in love with
her and I just love how like norm like I
don't know I just think it's so rare
when select couples in Hollywood like
have normal relationship progressions
like they dated for a good amount of
time got engaged for like a decent
amount of time got married well I never
got married after you won the World
Series right that's the normal part but
I'm just mean like the timing is so
normal I'm like they've been married for
now a couple months and she's pregnant
like just perfect perfect I was telling
my friends cuz and they don't know
anything about Brad culture except they
the only way they get their information
is from the toast if they don't want to
toast a know-nothing
so I'm saying Kate Upton's pregnant and
I think it's just so crazy that she's
our age because she's 26 she's born in
1982 and they were like what like they
thought she was like 30-something I was
a kid this is just like a girl our age
getting pregnant like with her husband
and just being the most beautiful woman
on the planet happens she was 26 huh
funny it's like I used to think 26 was
like an adult but like I'm 24 and like
I'm not an adult you know what I mean
yeah seems younger when you're it oh oh
you know I'm sure but when we're certain
like still math 30 seems like okay if
we're not like in a totally different
realm of life yeah 30 then we need to
rethink stuff but I'm not gonna be I
just think she also knows like the most
mature feminine body so like you don't
think of that as 26 like she to me she
is like a very similar body as like
Marilyn Monroe and to me Marilyn Monroe
was always like a woman you know not a
girl for sure except Marilyn Monroe like
I think died it young good oh yeah like
she never even made it to 30 no I don't
think I think she's part of 27 club and
the thing about Kate Upton is she's been
around for so long she feels like a
veteran mom that's true and you would
think uh veteran models in her 30s but
it's just because she started so young
because she was just so beautiful she
couldn't stop
yeah she couldn't talk and she's in
Miami for swim week and like everyone
Sports Illustrated is there and like it
just looks so let it it doesn't it
doesn't I guess like yeah cuz you know
they don't really think they want us to
look it to look like but like I know
they're not drinking and I know they're
not eating so like how much fun are you
really alright that's like revolve like
it looks fun but I think that we're
evolved is fun because I feel like
influencers do at least drink I mean I
don't know about eat not eat for sure
but drink is cool too um I love that the
toasters new this first and there I
didn't realize how many subgroups so if
you guys don't know we talk about all
the time our listeners have a feast but
group it's a private Facebook group
where they like swap stories summary
gossip recommendations all that stuff
and it's so late and like there's always
drama in like they always they new
Halley and Justin we're engaged way
before we did and they're like a couple
spin-off groups like ones that we
started and I didn't realize how many
they were like there's an Amazon one
it's called toasters in their prime and
I joined today because I want to see
like good deals do you know how many
subgroups there are how many there's
like there's not an exact number it's
like nobody really know because and also
like every city has one right but a
couple of duplicates mhm but some a
couple girls were commenting about how
many they were in so like the I
attribute the number of toaster groups
there are as the person who said they
were in the most groups so I want you to
guess oh well no I I don't think that
that that's even true but one other
sibling more than and is this not
including city groups because he she's
in every city oh that's true so there's
definitely way more yeah but there's no
like there's no way to quantify it
because like I don't I don't have a
place for them do you know what I mean
yeah I just want you to guess okay I
think subgroups not City 75 oh okay
relax 32 she was in this girl
oh no but she's in there's probably 50 I
don't think she's in every group no no
but I think there's probably 50 I think
there's more there's toasters with
chronic illnesses did you know that
no there's Weight Watchers toasters book
club toasters but then there's also just
like diet toasters cooking toaster yes
Beauty we have dog we have dog man whom
we have tipsy toasters we had the best
but there are just so many the lgbtq
toasters yes that's new then there's one
that's like I think like kind of toast
after dark ii-in
it's about like sex and like oh the
cheat I do the TI a there's so many
groups um there's there's the treasure
guard itself visual Seventh Art Kirby
toaster mom toasters teacher toasters we
already just counted 15 there's so many
and there's ones I've also never heard
of right let they just keep poppin I'm
like how do theirs steamy sue lease
teens yeah the people who love our
school like there's so many there's so
many there's some toasters stylish
scenes yes whatever there's just so many
it's so great so like and then plus the
city groups how many cities are there in
the US there's at 152 states
yeah that's 52 groups 5250 I was like
what I knew that I don't know a lot
about America like in history and like I
was letting this conversation in the car
I was just getting ahead of myself
ya know just having this conversation in
the car yesterday with Olivia like about
how I really don't know like history
like I do not know you don't know famous
couple sorry I don't know who fought in
the Cold War and then Olivia told me and
then I remember that movie with a little
bit of Cuba Cuba I just I don't know
things about like our country do you
know any mean well I'm a history major
and you are like a wealth of knowledge
check even Olivia are always talking
about [ __ ] and I feel like that episode
of Friends where Joey like it's the
encyclopedia and he doesn't know what
anyone's talking about like that's me
know it really is nice to just know
about your past and it's like they say
like if you don't understand the past
you're destined to repeat it in the
future and I just don't want to be one
of those people yeah and I was like a
major as a college degree history is
like a little bit worthless but just as
a woman of the world totally it's very
worth full I agree and really yeah I
feel like you should read a couple
history books or no I'm sorry don't do
that because you never will watch a few
movies
okay that's treasure for sure two quads
like Black Hawk Down don't know what
that is it's a it's a crazy shocking
story about about the u.s. trying to
help Somalia and it's an epic fail okay
it does not have a happy ending oh okay
it's but it's like I've never know this
story I saw 13 reasons why with Benghazi
Rosa called 30 minutes verse 13 hours
yes 13 hours why 13 reason that I best
movie ever Ghazi Chucky the plane never
came no it's the worst movie ever like
even when they're safe and sound
it's not an American plane what's wrong
with us
such a crazy movie and John Krasinski
was like hot it and he's like nah there
were so many hotties but I was like
there they're not okay
save our Hattie totally bring back our
hotties I saw I know it wasn't real I
wish it was and glorious bastards
learned a lot about that I'ma be I need
to see his Valkyrie really why cuz they
tried to kill Hitler but they did it and
then Tom Cruise wears a fake but yes he
learn what did he play Hitler no he was
just tryin us like he was playing like a
military and he were fake buddy went
viral Oh mother that's hysterical so for
that reason you should see it um other
historical films I don't know I want to
see that one about Churchill that
doesn't look like darkest hour yeah it
won all the Oscars I'm just not my bad
and it's like now that there are all
these real movies about our history and
about famous couple sister um it's like
how can you watch movies that are just
made up completely like it's a useless
you know it's like Oh fake do something
better with your time right like learn
about something that's why I watch
reality TV it's real and that no I I
feel the exact same way and I was
talking about this with my friends the
only scripted TV that I watch is stuff
that's so far fetched like Game of
Thrones yeah that like it's not like oh
my god these people that are living
realize that I want to watch people are
living real lives
I'll watch your Housewives like I don't
watch about Oh a family just like us yes
there's Modern Family right we are the
modern family we web show and then the
other shows that I watch are like
dynasty and Riverdale that's just like
glamour fantasy beautifully yeah and if
it's not that if it's other people's
problems that are made up I am NOT
interested
yeah like shows that give you a pit for
other people that aren't even real waste
of time
I can't innocent no but like I'm
watching a reality show is multifaceted
because like you get to watch but then
you also get to like watch them in real
life and like on social media and that's
like a whole other show like Sheena and
that Adam the bartender like Vic I think
they're dating like that is a show in
and of itself and then I'll get to see
it unfold and let's see what really
happens a hundred percent like siesta
key like even though the show is a
little bit fake like
social media is real and it just it
keeps it going throughout the season
also Chloe Troutman of fiesta key is
gonna be at my show in Denver
Chloe trout me and peer pressured me
into going out on Saturday night and
honestly like when you told everyone to
tell me to go out and like everyone was
telling me I was like okay I understand
and then she messaged me she's like you
have to go out it's your sister's
birthday and I was like oh my god Khloe
and I went I could just see her like
being like I'm the show yeah you have to
go out
that's an episode but she's gonna be at
my show in Denver I think her boyfriend
loves her I mean a cute I don't know
like I don't know why she would be in
Denver so I'm Carly I think so too so do
you wanna see Claire Chapman go buy
tickets girls no job home oh my god that
is so cute
we never even talked about how Friday we
posted the video to your birthday oh my
god we they talked about that Jackie
made literally and I take absolutely no
credit for it the most incredible vlog
for our youtube patreon subscribers and
if he's just like our night from start
to finish at my birthday party
everyone is so drunk I'm like talking to
the camera like embarrassing themselves
like definitely the documentary sort of
filmed itself yet one person that it
wouldn't have been the same without it's
been like Oh Ben is the star he is the
star he is so funny watching him get
progressively
Richburg yeah is hilarious and then Dana
always honorable mention because she
always comes through so if you're not a
patreon member I would honestly just
subscribe for this month if you don't
want to do every month because it's so
good and then you get access to all of
our old episodes which are a bunch of
other videos some podcast some just we
do like we do really good like in-depth
podcasts on certain topics like we did a
whole health and beauty one we did a
whole New York guide so it's worth it it
is worth it and we're definitely gonna
continue our mini series behind the
scenes maybe once Mitch comes home we'll
do like something see nature when she
becomes our intern reluctantly I can't
wait to boss her around
no can't wait can't enchant book next
sequence Louise official christening
photos with the royal family you guys
Prince Louise christening photos came
out there was a whole array of them
every the nuclear family the extended
family the royal family every photo more
precious than the next every photo more
precious than the next and everything I
needed and more and honestly props to
Kensington Palace are being so [ __ ]
in tune with what's necessarily like
every time there's a
like they get the most premium pictures
and they released them like we care and
like we want pictures and we don't get
enough of them so like thank you for
that and like all I can think about is
how like back in the day like if the
commoners wanted to see a picture of the
Royals they would have to wait for that
to be painted and they left like sit for
hours where's like we get it the next
day that's true but then also back in
the day like it we just be in the
newspaper like I remember in the crown
like Margaret's writings birthday
portraits like a whole thing right and
she does it you know it's all over my
explore page and I'm just so happy for
it and this picture with will Kate Louie
George
Charlotte Charlotte is so cute Camilla
Charles Harry and Egham is the picture
okay it's the photo and here's why Megan
looks fake like she looks like a doll
like she looks like Barbie Charlotte is
impeccably cute they all are George has
never looked happier George is never
liked happier George steals the
spotlight in every photo but Kate looks
so beautiful like I feel like she's like
a real mom do you know what Amy and I
feel like she really sacrifices like her
own like self care just like to take
care of her kids like she always looks
like so busy and like so like she's like
a real mom like she's just like not that
she's even it relatable whatsoever
because she's like a staff but like she
just looks like she's always putting her
kids her son I remember like there was a
paparazzi photo of like her hair turning
gray and like she needed care cuz like
she was just headed Charlotte like she
finally took a moment for herself and
she looks so beautiful in these photos
her contours on fleek her headpiece was
divine and then that I don't know what
they call it but like that big blanket
she was carrying the baby and was just
glamorous as how it's so glamorous and
the whole family looks great but where
is Queenie
where's Queenie vibes I don't know I'm
not sure but obviously the only thing I
can really look at in this photo is
Megan because this is like her first
royal portrait not from her wedding her
dress is like a little dark and
everyone's wearing kind of bright colors
so it is a little darkening but she
looks beautiful she looks beautiful and
like I can't even assess her outfit
because I'm just so happy that she's
there yeah her and Harry look like a
little nervous like they're working
really hard to look normal like they're
robots like she looks like a Stepford
wife in the picture and you know what
Camila doesn't look nervous enough like
yeah shoulders back woman yeah I'm not
here for Camila and Charles like they
couldn't just scram and leave us with
the new job
raishin of royals well it's like I
didn't know about Camilla and Charles
for so long like before I started
watching the crown before no before
Megan was introduced to the royal family
I didn't know that Charles would even
like remarry the divorce woman I didn't
know that there was drama there were
three moment women in their relationship
and like that's why him and Diana broke
up and Lake Charles was in love with
Camilla since before he ever meant to
yeah right but it was a large barrier
because she was forced and so in the one
hand I just want to be like and no he
wasn't allowed to marry her before Diana
because she wasn't a virgin like how
[ __ ] crazy is that sure even divorce
yet so gravely so crazy so they just got
married like this whole scandal
oh so Megan markle's a virgin this whole
scandal would have been eradicated but
we wouldn't have had the princess that
we have today because that's true the
DNA would have made yeah it would have
been still Ansari right so I'm great
also yep I'm grateful that we have will
and Harry wait oh my god check it I got
tagged in literally the loot like the
lamest meme ever but there's an account
dedicated to like justifying Diana's
existence so someone like took all the
royal portraits and like cut out Camille
its face and like tags me and they're
like much better it's so late that is so
lame I get I see some really bad meat
meat you do I could take them all the
time that's true people tagged me and
memes like I don't know I'm gonna send
them to you maybe I would if it were
really funny but can you stop yeah I in
tag them all like and speaking of Royals
over the weekend
oh yeah been bailed in was lit as hell
because at Memel did two amazing things
happened Meghan and Kate like went on
their first outing together alone
without the boys and they just like sad
for everyone like watch the match and
they looked really cute and happy and
laughy and like what are they laughing
about I have right now what do they talk
about I mean people are saying like they
have a lot to like discuss because like
they're both technically commoners but I
mean Kate is like British and Kate like
grew up in like royal aristocrat to see
and like Megan's like an American
actress like they couldn't be a more
different
they really could I don't know what they
talked about what did they laugh about
too and they are those real laughs her
fake glasses right like for the photos I
want to believe that they're real apps
and then also at my milled in Belen
estan were reunited had an affair Luke
don't tell the Beast Luke Evans and Emma
Watson we're sitting next to each other
at one of the matches and like literally
like goals goals and I really do go back
and forth on who Belle should have gone
with
and I feel like she should have gotten
with Gaston because like the beast was
like I love that they come on
I want date do you know what I mean no
so I've seen the movie many times and I
also saw the movie as a kid the cartoon
and obviously when you're a kid you're
just like bad Gaston good beast and now
even when I started maybe the first time
I was like oh so romantic beast and then
now that I've literally watched it 75
thousand times and I've really watched
it was like an analytical lens and like
I watched all the special features like
I look through it now and it's like when
I watch guest John in every scene
literally all he wants to do is make
about happy and like matter he doesn't
say like oh well I'm gonna [ __ ] you and
you know throw you to the wolves he said
I want to marry you and have children
with you how nice like and she's so rude
to him back like really he didn't do
anything here he's just hotter which
isn't a crime the only bad thing he does
is he captures Maurice and then like but
because he wanted him punished but her
family had like thrown him aside so many
times and just like degraded him to like
the point of just belittling him to like
this tiny thing where like yes I'd be
pissed - [ __ ] you Maurice and you're you
and your gears you know totally know if
you watch the movie through that lens
it's wildly interesting because you
realize Bella's so rude to him from the
get-go and really he doesn't do anything
bad until she pushes him to that point
so I just think it's everyone should
watch him again through the lens of
guest on being the good guy and like the
beast he [ __ ] capturing your dad and
held you captive
it's an abusive relationship okay here's
the thing that's one extreme but you all
you don't have to watch it through the
lens of Gaston being the good guy but
watch you through the lens of Gaston
isn't really that bad and then like he's
a real suitor what the only problem is
is that he only wants Mary Belle because
she's beautiful but like she is
beautiful inside and out it's a
compliment
he never said she was on the inside I
just think like everyone being so here
for the beast and not Gaston it's like
hypocritical I really never say they're
the same sorry no no I'm here for the
beasts like as a man in general like
also recluse lives in his big home
doesn't want to leave love it like he's
so cute and tender and honestly like
it's the lesser of two evils
both of the guys are bad like they both
do bad things sir like she should have
ended up with Lefou but Lefou is not
interested in her no Lefou in the new
sequels gay right
and did you hear the wouldn't play it in
some countries because Lefou is gay like
oh my god doesn't like Dupin the movie
before movie came out he was like a
whole thing I think maybe gay and like
but never even all these like cities
were like an uproar but it was just a
very subtle nuance at the end like I
didn't even like you just take a xanax
calm down everyone needs to calm down
everyone needs to take a guess tone on
the kind of gratis food totally yes John
on the count of three one two three yeah
that's good that was great now we have
to move on from the story yes whenever
we look at this story too well because
that was the best at everyone but one
more piece of royal news Thomas Marko is
on the loose again
oh he's claiming that Megan's Tara she
was terrified in every photo with the
royal family and he just wants to talk
to her and honestly like I think he has
good intentions and he doesn't realize
every time he speaks he makes a big duty
everywhere like he thinks like I think
he's a good person and he's really just
like trying to help I think he really
does think Megan looks terrified but you
know tell that to the president tell it
to your new wife it's like a trial he's
trying to be helpful and he literally
just ends up taking a massive dump
everywhere I really feel so sorry for
him but like my party talks the more I'm
just like I you're losing all of my
sympathy it would really behoove her
just to reach out to him and be like he
just needs to shut the [ __ ] up he's
making her look like such a mess that if
she reaches out to him like he's gonna
screenshot that Andros it to Instagram
he's gonna tell the telly tonight Megan
texted me today here's her phone number
Megan's alive yeah like he's out of
control he's really out of control and
once again justice for Megan Merkel's
mom who just is a class act
even though her ex-husband is
legitimately a psychopath no truly like
how are they ever married that's crazy
and whatever and what I hear not that I
was there but they had a very tumultuous
marriage like his family was really mean
to her oh that's so sad I know I'm glad
she got out and now she's the wife of
the mother of you know she couldn't be
in a better spot does she live in London
I wonder where she's residing like if
you like your only daughter was the
queen of England like you would move
right if your only daughter it was
Queenie vibe no Megan is Queenie vibe Oh
totally it is Queen like not just vibes
sake all around Megan Queenie vibes only
wait so you know I've been ordering off
of Instagram my grandma are you Taylor
Swift 1994 okay so I got I ordered off
of another Instagram ad and it was a
little shady because the company was
called
vibes season which like is the loser
rias name ever but they had these name
plates that say like in the year you
were born so it's so cute and I got one
then I also was like oh I'll get another
one with my name and it came and they
did it in like Old English letters and
it's all lowercase so I open it I'm like
something looks weird and I show Ben and
he's like I like i know what i'm
thinking is weird but i think
homage what is he a song yeah he's like
it says Dahlia I'm like yeah okay so
sorry yeah cuz it's all lowercase so
like though he the little C and L just
look like a D and I'm against Dahlia
look what am I gonna do with the cyclist
so stupid just call me da da and now I'm
all tangled and like nothing bothers me
more than having making Gomes da Tia
it's so stupid so funny and like maybe
I'm just looking too much into it so I
showed it to Ben he's like your daughter
yeah no totally that's like Altea hmm
when Olivia was younger she got scratch
I like the magazine she's got like a
magazine her name
Alton yeah hey LT IV I'm literally still
call her that we don't let anything
going on family like that's that's proof
like you didn't we beat Margot up with
parson that was only like five years
right that's now breast yeah on the
cover of highlights magazine the chili
was maybe she's 20 she's definite maybe
20 years ago oh my god maybe more than
20 years ago we don't let anybody know
that LT via it comes from that cuz
that's just like one of her names
let me call her tibbar which might come
from tamiya know it was live tube tube
no in his teens because of I'll tip and
then Tim became Tim but it was briefly
to Barocci
it was briefly tears down ya know we
call her everything Liberace
taraji that's what I called her for like
a summer she needed so much you maybe
stop my cousin's trout because I thought
Oliver Roger and I thought that if
origins name was Oliver trout but it's
Oliver Twist it is yes who's Oliver
child movie I don't think so maybe it's
our my movie now and then I called her
trout skins oh wow he'll Sevilla okay
you guys everyone somber I'm fine
you're smiling stop smiling I'm happy no
you're having a word wedding morning
show what's not to be happy you're not
gonna be happy after this next story oh
god okay bombshell Anthony Bourdain
interview is published one month after
his suicide
celebrity chef unloads on quote rapey
and
gropey and disgusting Bill Clinton and
hopes Weinstein is beaten to death in
jail okay
these are good daily now bullets where
is the Internet of the interview from
like who was a with um popular with
journalists Maria Bustillos okay like oh
it hadn't been published until now shady
Anthony Bourdain gave a lengthy
wide-ranging interview to journalist
Maria Bastille owes for her recently
launched magazine popular in the
interview conducted in February and
published Sunday 14th slam Bill
Clinton's handling of his sexual
misconduct allegations he also condemned
Clinton's wife Hillary for her role in
destroying the women Bourdain one of the
most outspoken male supporters of the me
to movement said he would have liked to
see the producer quote beaten to death
in his cell everyone's about Harvey
Weinstein he also touched on politics in
the Trump era saying he would compromise
his principles for some quote [ __ ]
competency which I don't have reading
either but here's one also bizarrely
said Jericho's eyebrows appeared
manscaped said he was quote born a
snitch that is oh my god he's talking to
us from beyond Anthony Bourdain was me
tear you and we will get your story out
I mean this just confirms what we
already knew and he told us and it was
already suspicious when Anthony Bourdain
was announced that he had committed
suicide I've been following him on
Twitter for a while and because his
girlfriend of a long time was one of
Harvey Weinstein's victims he was like
super outspoken about all like the
misogyny in pedophilia in Hollywood and
it was a matter of time before they took
him down similar to Mark Salling mark
sailing for don't quote committed
suicide ironically
a day before he was due at the LAPD to
give names of some of Hollywood's
biggest pedophiles in exchange for a
better sentencing to you literally the
day before he could give up some of
Hollywood's pedophiles he was
quote-unquote found dead from committing
suicide even though the police report
was very conflicting cuz it said he had
defensive brooms but that he also
committed suicide and how would you have
defensive wounds if it was you killed
yourself an but nobody cared cuz like he
was like a terrible guy and they're like
whatever he's a child molester a child
pornography whatever like but now
Anthony Bourdain is like literally one
of the most people were so the points
guy because I didn't realize he like
Anthony Bourdain is like travel like
he's just like a lot of people like
really looked up to him and the points
guy was like easily
like one of my biggest inspirations I'm
like for me I was just like I just
follow him on Twitter but like for some
people like he was like everything okay
so now I feel like the world is quietly
waking up to all the what's going on but
nobody really cared about mark sterling
cuz he was like Medaille dand he was a
terrible person
whatever Anthony Bourdain is like this
universally respected person and now
things are happening you know about like
things are have anyone had his needs
this interview came out but nothing's
gonna come of it like no one's
questioning whether or not was if he
committed suicide like literally the
headline still says one month after his
suicide right let's at least say one
month after his death because now this
is just and then let's change it to one
month after his murder this just is even
more proof that what empty saying is
probably true like he knew so much about
like you know the real corruption that
went all the way up in Hollywood and
like he was ready to talk about it like
he's the type of person where he's
successful enough and has made enough
money that he doesn't rely on Hollywood
I feel like a lot of the people who are
victims of like the terrible things that
go on in Hollywood like still need to
work or they need to make money and they
need to like live but Anthony Bourdain
he was at a level like he was
unreachable so he could say whatever he
wants but now we can't that's crazy
so maybe he really couldn't say whatever
he wants and that just goes to show
we're out of control talking like this
right totally
and you know what else I hate like I
hate that talking like this like makes
me look like a crazy conspiracy theorist
cuz it's true but like it's not
mainstream so I'm like I look like crazy
because I like you know what I mean yeah
it's annoying
no it really it's very annoying but I'm
not a crazy conspirators that guy that
like has all the conspiracy theories on
YouTube that people say is crazy I don't
know I don't know like I feel like that
person even though I'm spitting and no I
I feel like when we do this show the
toasters know what's up and like I don't
feel like a conspiracy theorist talking
to them but like when I talk to other
people and they're like oh my god so sad
about Anthony Bourdain I'm like well he
was murdered because he was speaking
about about Harvey Weinstein like right
I sound so crazy and then I go into all
of the craziest Minds just to prove that
it's even that's nothing it's easy that
the girl the little girl from
poltergeist afraid to death and then
like I always close with that yeah and I
feel so crazy I feel crazy and like
literally last night in my sleep I had a
thought and I remembered being like
write this down but I didn't but now I'm
murmuring that like I can't believe that
there are people who like live in this
world and are just they're like fully
conscious and they're like real people
who just believed like that everything
they see on social media and everything
they
in the press about Selena Gomez is true
do you know what I mean like they don't
know that like Selena Gomez it has two
sides and like the real side of the fake
side like just these people who like who
are well informed and like follow her
Instagram just like think she's like a
pop singer like there are so many people
who just like to think that do you know
anything and that she's like a role
model and like probably doesn't even
really drink right she said even just
like on the base level now people who
think she's wrong I'll just people who
know about her existence right and
they're just like oh yeah she's an
American pop singer like that's not even
the half of it you know
totally man Oh Alex Jones that's the guy
who does all the conspiracy theories
that's me now what does he conspire I
don't know but that's me I'm just like
everywhere I go something talking myself
and I'm like well you know he didn't
really die James Dean's been living up
in Canada like I'm and it sounds so
crazy but I'm not know totally like I
just don't want to be stigmatized like
Alex Jones is the crazy conspiracy
person because my conspiracy theories
are definitely true no it's not because
no one calls empty conspiracy theorists
right and as long as you're basing
everything we say off of empty like I
think we're okay meanwhile this brings
me to my next story because I'm I'm so
conflicted Claudia they say Alex Jones
thinks the Sandy Hook school shooting
was fake
like that's not many I have legitimate
to get don't compare us outs and yeah
this next story is very conflicting for
us because Elon Musk oh my god I can't
even talk about this here we'll just
read the headline the news and then
we'll talk about wait commit weep before
I was gonna preface that I knew we were
gonna talk about the story and last
night when I also couldn't sleep I was
thinking about what I was gonna say and
I was like I have to defend any less to
the death and then I'm also thinking um
I'm not his sister like what do I owe to
my lawyers like he doesn't even know who
we all right like if we thought that
like he knew that we loved him and now
we're gonna turn on him like no I want
to read the whole story so that we can
really look last night I was like I'm
gonna defend him to the death I love him
and then I'm like why so now you go hard
for people and I gave up on people
because I don't know maybe he was like I
am biased for sure but like now I'm
gonna do it through a lens that's
completely unbiased and apolitical
go furious Elon Musk calls Thailand Cave
Rescue Diver quote a pedo as in Peter
vile
maybe now I haven't called anyone a pedo
pedo like literally than 15 you know and
like Twitter up there word
I couldn't you spell work maybe you
didn't meet pedophile so give the over
the out outline Elon Musk launched
ambitious Twitter attacks Sunday against
one of the divers who helped rescue a
group of boys from a tie cave last week
calling him a pedo after the frogman
criticized the Tesla Chiefs failed bid
to aid the situation Vern Unsworth who
was on the international team of
specialist cave divers at the scene had
told CNN that he thought the mini
submarine the Tesla chief sent to help
with the rescue was a useless grab for
attention Unsworth said Musk's mini-subs
done in fact got in the way of the
rescue quote it just had absolutely no
chance of working
he had no conception of what the cave
passage was like the submarine I believe
was about five feet six inches long
rigid so wouldn't have gone round
corners around any obstacles Unsworth
said it wouldn't have made the first
fifty meters into the cave from the dive
start point it was just a PR stunt
Unsworth said musk was asked to lead the
Cape as quote he should have been he
went at Highland oh I didn't know that
huh musclin tweeted of Unsworth never
saw this British expat guy who lives in
Thailand suss at any point when we were
in the caves only people in sight were
the Thai Navy Sasha army guys who were
great Thai Navy SEALs escorted us in
total opposite of wanting us to leave
what early level was actually very low
and still not flowing you could
literally have swum 2k5 with no gear
which is avec ID's got in if not true
then I challenged this dude to show
final rescue video huge credit to pump
and generator team unsung heroes here
musk added you know what don't bother
showing the video musk Road we will make
one of the mini-sub slash pod going all
the way to k5 no problemo
sorry pedo guy you really did ask for it
ok so the interview I had I saw the
interview first people were circulating
it basically that Ilan just did this
whole thing for press and I was like
that's so mean cuz like I don't think
he's a bad person and then Ilan and then
I heard he called him a pedophile and I
tried to go on Elance Twitter literally
I just called out so far he's being
crazy like replying to everyone like
he's spiraling out of control and here's
what's really conflicting because
honestly after everything I've read on
the internet it seems like a lot of
people are pedophiles and that doesn't
even shock me any right but this is
what's completing is that NT tweeted to
burn
Unsworth if you want someone to
represent you against Elon Musk for live
or libel I will do it so free he said
it'll do it free so NT is taking
Burnside right undoubtedly meaning that
burn is definitely not a pedophile right
just to like D stigmatize and like
normalize the word pedophile is stupid
because like there is a lot of
pedophilia that people aren't talking
about so like I don't agree with Elon
they're like that's not a cool word to
use but also like if it's really coming
out of nowhere why would you say that on
your so you can search that it's a
random insults like only so based in
facts his whole life is facts and
science I'm number I would you
throughout not a fact well this is just
a weird cuz I feel like there are very
few people left in the world who
everyone respects and likes like Elon
Musk before this whole fiasco was just
like this the genius of our generation
like was had a great business like
wanted to go to the moon you know like
he just like everyone thought he was
like this revered like godlike character
and now he's like this one thing is
gonna take him down and I don't think
the Internet is extremely unforgiving I
agree but I think Elon Musk has done so
much good that this shouldn't undo him
they should also like her I really don't
understand what like why he said pedo
and not pedophile right less you think
it was a time like people are saying
that the cave diver is considering
considering suing Elon but like just
pedo hold up as an insult in a court of
law
it's abbreviated right good question
maybe he meant to write pedal pedal
pedal pedal like why maybe that maybe he
meant say pedal like a dog right I don't
know or paleo I don't know I don't mean
we should be a meal and legal defense
team totally like I don't but I'm not
defending me on in the situation but I
still love him I still support him I
don't think what he did was a PR sin and
even if it was like I really think he
was trying to help
no I don't think he built a submarine
like went to all those links I don't
know I didn't go to Thailand to like for
PR you know and masculine area has more
than enough BR
right and this show is just like it
non-stop churning out content for Elon
Musk machine but it's just so weird and
like now I'm like I'm reading his tweets
like he's he's Alex Jones like he's like
literally mean crazy like that sorry
what he said that about you he just like
he looks crazy like in his tweets like
no
responding to everyone well you should
tweet I didn't be like him on the show
totally I'd hold on so you're really
active on Twitter at come on my show if
all the toasters tweet at him like he'll
see it actually maybe someone took his
phone away
now hopefully I just feel like Ilan step
away from the computer you go back to
test go back to the lab go back to the
lab go back to that then something so
amazing that we're all going to forget
about this fiasco like I don't know
maybe a plane that gets you from LA to
New York in five minutes well this is
what we were talking about this morning
because New York now has these things
those link machines that I guess like
have internet and people use it to watch
porn and master meet which is like one
use but another use is that they tell
you these random facts about New York
there was a big digital like
advertisements right some facts are
really weird but some are really helpful
so on this today I saw on this day and I
guess 1958 1958 sometime in the 1950s
John Glenn broke world records by flying
a jet from New York to California in
three hours and 20 minutes okay 60 years
let's look at let's do the math please
it's been what's it is the year 2018
it's been six years 60 years 70 years 70
years ago someone had the technology to
get us to meet California in three hours
2018 60 years later
70 years later it still takes six hours
where's that technology I always think
that and I always use the example from
New York to LA as as my product analyst
why because you could be in Dallas or LA
no but LA to New York is a very popular
commute for people who work and just
like coast to coast and it's so frequent
and like there's so many flights that
like you'd think they'd be working
overtime to make that specific flight
like as easy as possible but no no you
would think that like when they have a
technology it's not just New York to LA
that took three hours anywhere could
take half the time they have this
technology yet 70 years later it still
hasn't been implemented even though John
Glenn yeah did that and then went to the
moon League member national treasure men
was a nice guy and hidden figures
remember a national treasure in one of
the sequels there was this book hidden
in the White House about or it had it
hidden in the Reagan Library about all
the presidents like there's
secrets like they would write it after
they were their president like one of
the president secrets is totally that he
knows how to fight from New York to LA
in like 20 minutes but won't cherry
because he wants to just use it for
himself no but like it's just the
airlines I mean this just goes back to
the airlines and how there's totally
defunct in Korea and corrupt and like
taxpayer dollars and not at work they
are not oh no I need to do a full expose
on just the airline do you want to use
them yeah on the airlines in general
because it's [ __ ] up no it's so [ __ ]
up and now that I saw this like New York
doesn't even know what it has coming
because we should like we should be
protesting for better technology on
planes did you see this story I was
looking for stories today and there was
a flight I think it might have been
right no I don't want to defame look it
was it but it was flying to Croatia
somewhere from somewhere in Europe and
it plummeted 30,000 feet like the plane
just went down they landed safely but
the passengers were bleeding from there
yes I did hear about the ears that's all
I heard about but I didn't know that
they had plummeted they plummet did they
crash or they put yourselves up
they picked themselves up and they
landed safely but like also have ever
like busted out their ears right that's
so scary that's probably so dangerous
like for your ears I that's so scary
we need better technology on planes and
apparently it exists John Glenn if only
he were here to see this no there's so
much like John Glenn is rolling in his
grave
clearly there's so many like secrets in
our country do you know what I mean and
like Angie's uncovering some of them but
like I just feel like there's so much
that goes on that we don't even know
about
we need like government empty right like
Argo our group was kept a secret up
until like 10 years ago up until Ben
Affleck's out now right he found the
files and then even made a movie about
it and that's how the whole world
thought out really that guy was given a
Purple Heart in secret like in the
parking lot remember yeah no I didn't
see Argo and water I know oh my god
hostage crisis no Johnny like it's the
biggest Pitt the whole movie is one day
I can't like did you ever see the movie
like I'm Ted Bay that was about the
Israeli flash I know but not 10 yeah his
brother oh my god yes it's his brother
oh my god and no one even knows his
story I don't really know the story
either but it's like a plane hostage
situation he's a clean hostage situation
an Israeli flight they took it like all
the way to South America and like it was
just it ever and dog don't tell me
totally okay it's a horrible horrible no
but the current president of Israel's
brother was that he and he died right I
don't know just tell me I want
but he was the war hero he's like and
that's why his brother is like so famous
and well-liked cuz like his brothers his
brothers guests on whose riders on Teddy
you guys should see on Kevin II just so
people like I feel like it's it to the
Argo of Israel but it just doesn't have
Ben Affleck I can't leave you haven't
seen our no Jackie it's okay so good day
I thought of watching it gives me a bit
like I know what I know what happened
the only movie in the past maybe 10
years that I've watched that gate that
like that was like it gave me app it was
um 13 hours because like I just I cannot
watch Pitts movies anymore like you you
watch the keepers you and Olivia keeping
yeah anything about it I won't watch it
guys I can't watch things that give me
here's the difference 13 hours it's like
we all knew what was gonna happen touch
what was not happening and just sitting
there like wait like knowing that no
one's coming for these guys like that
was the pit keepers I had no clue what
where this story was gonna go so I'm
just like interested and I thought and I
couldn't like him it's now had like hope
that something positive was gonna happen
which it sort of did right 13 hours
nothing positive was happening
no one was cut I don't even know what
the people know what's coming for our
hotties like things that are so [ __ ]
up like the keepers know it's just about
the church and all the like spot dad sad
but now justice has been served a little
bit okay I don't care I just like I had
me tell us fake I don't care I choose to
watch friends like I want to watch happy
positive things that make me laugh I'm
so done with like being inundated with
sadness and guys I have no time for
handmade tell like movies that I mean
shows that are so fake and like but
they're making think that that's gonna
happen to I was actually talking about
this with my friends because they watch
and me too and it was like how do you
guys watch that stuff / what Steven
about it's like the future but we're
living on a farm
everyone's Amish and like comfort has
destroyed the world and they were like
that's literally what it's about and
everyone's like oh my god this is so
close to home but it's like we don't
have a fertility issue apparently that's
what it's all based on I have no idea
I'm just not watching it like I have
made a conscious decision in my life
like oh my god people tell me all
someone just her hammy tail is insane
everyone should be so afraid of fascism
I'm already afraid of fascism without
watching him me tell I read history I
didn't know if I don't need to watch a
snake show to know that fascism is not
good I don't even know if that's like
Nazism oh definitely not good I'm just
like I I've made it the consciousness
as an adult to only like be happy do you
know any mean like people ask me all the
time you know I've dealt with a good
amount of trauma in my life and I think
you're so strong they're like on
Father's Day people like did you cry
with no I just don't want to bet people
all the time they're like did you get
sad I'm like no I don't want to cry and
I have made the conscious decision to
not be sad and people are like you're so
cold like we don't cry I'm like no you
know what I want to be happy why would I
want to make myself cry like I'm just
I'm over it like I have made a decision
to be happy I don't want to watch sad
movies I don't want to think about said
things like I want to be happy and I'm
gonna live my life in a positive way
like I don't want to cry on Father's Day
it's a happy day like people who
celebrate and you know and be happy you
don't have to buy a card in the gift and
like spend the day like I can just watch
TV at home I know it's a breezy I
haven't most relaxing Father's Day but
other people ask me like if I want to
hang out I'm like sorry it's just like a
tough day for me you know even that's
not and you got the day off and I get
you use it as an excuse you know I'm
just I try to see the positives and like
the benefits and I just I don't want to
be sad therefore I will not be sad and
therefore we won't be watching handmaids
town yeah speaking of amazing TV that we
must recap southern charm finale aired
on Thursday I didn't get to watch it
until last night
Oh drama it was wild it was everything I
thought it was going to be and so now I
just want to talk about the things that
I didn't expect the the confrontation
between ash tank has and I feel like at
this point between all the previews and
the flashbacks I just saw the whole
thing
I pretty much saw the whole thing she's
out of control wild I cannot believe her
and Thomas are still together like she's
so crazy and she has some we talked
about this on the NT episode of patreon
that she has something on Thomas and
that's why he's not letting her go and
there's a lot of like rumors as to what
it could be I know but at this time mr.
Ravenel scares me so I'm not saying
anything
six-eight yeah everyone knows I know a
couple like journalists who write about
this kind of stuff have seen it and what
is it entail I'm not gonna tell you
because it's gross okay anyways she has
something on him he's not cutting her
loose
definitely still paying her bills yeah
very scary now I wasn't is all just like
don't you feel like you're watching for
no reason because it's all supposed to
come to like this come to a head at the
Reunion and Thomas isn't even there to
speak and like own up to his [ __ ] so
it's like you're getting so invested and
you're never gonna get what you want
because Thomas is probably done with the
shelf
agreed and then at the end of the show
they did like a six months later Todd
and Zack and I were home it was like
oceans the room was so dark we didn't
know what was gonna come up on the
screen we're like sitting there like
squeezing each other and it was like six
months later Ashley and Thomas are still
together period we're like okay video of
Kathryn and Thomas dancing in their
living room you saw that's it so cute
however Kathryn and Thomas are happily
co-parenting we're like okay okay and
then there was one more thing I don't
remember it nothing about the
allegations anything so how are they
gonna they shouldn't you know what they
should have just written it so they
don't have to say anything at the
Reunion now they have to address it but
they're addressing it at the Reunion
that's so what's frustrating is like
apparently from the reunion like it's so
crazy like actually is off of her rocker
nuts like mean nuts everything but I
think at the end people really start to
feel bad for her they like she's so
skinny but he's clearly like brainwash
brainwash like something's wrong woman
and it's like so she's gonna get off
scot-free B just cuz she's been
brainwashed
right like it's annoying that neither of
them are gonna be held accountable not
even Ashley because like eventually
we're gonna feel sorry for her that
she's under Thomas's thumb I also feel
torn because like Oh miss the last part
was that Catherine got 50/50 custody so
it's like oh it's so great yeah well
she's about to get 100 that's even
better
I just feel torn when it comes to Thomas
because I [ __ ] despise him he's
discussing misogynistic like he brought
Ashlee into our lives and he should be
punished forever but also like I want
him I want Catherine's kids have like a
good life and like a happy family and
like that video of them dancing is so
cute so you want to see that side but
like you know that's not really who he
is No however like there isn't happy
ending in all of this like just as a
server Thomas cats no for Catherine no
no like justice against yes justice is
served in the criminal court system
nice choice whatever punishment he
requires Catherine gets 100% custody and
therefore she will get child support
from him randos and she and the kids
want the money that they need that's so
for the rest of their lives that ravenel
Trust Fund just keeps cashing those
checks because until now she has been
having to pay him child support because
he had a hundred percent custody she was
only paying him a hundred dollars a
month like I guess that's the minimum
right because it wasn't about the money
but she had to pay him because he was
taking care of it it's so funny like I
feel like child support is like always
because them it's like a single mom
situation you gotta hunt down the dad
for money ya know the other parent like
has
right mom so let's yacht custody back
and I'm sure she's well on her way just
having full custody and so now I just
want to talk about the episode because
Patricia finally invited her to the big
gala invited who Catherine Catherine no
I don't hear watch I mean I know what's
going on and I follow everyone on social
media but Jackie like teaches me you
also have to know the history in order
to understand the future so it doesn't
repeat itself
right because Patricia's shun Catherine
since day one calling her a shameless
strumpet like bah-bah-bah I think
because she saw a lot of Catherine like
a lot of herself in Catherine and like
Catherine's the younger version of her
and Patricia throws these parties every
year and just doesn't even invite
Catherine's like Catherines being
shunned from filming essentially oh
right you know they Whitney's a producer
right so this season like so many people
talked about how great Catherine is and
how she's really changed and so Patricia
gives her a chance and invites I saw a
net when Naomi tried to talk to Patricia
and she walks away it was so rude that
was really sad oh my god and then you
talked about Naomi - but first so
Catherine comes she's like looks so
glamorous and amazing and it's a white
tie which I even know was a thing where
men have to wear tails girls have to
wear white gloves like it's even bigger
than that and everyone's talking about
this party this party this party like
Patricia's gala it was was it on her
house no it was at an event space that
also might have been a middle school
auditorium okay it was the saddest thing
and it's like they couldn't film from
too far away because I even see that I
said it was it was like the tables at
the party were only for the cast members
like there was no one else at the party
like it was a fake party in an
auditorium that was like so [ __ ] sad
and everyone's dressed to the nines it
looked like a costume party like it was
so sad and like they tried to make you
think like there's like a fake snow
machine outside and now it's like
there's all this white stuff on the
floor and like they literally were in a
middle school gym I feel like Patricia
is like fake rich like she just has a
really nice house that I feel like she
got in a divorce and like didn't have to
pay for and who just assumed she's rich
because the house is so gorgeous but
like she never leaves the house and
she's always wearing a caftan that she
got on Amazon so maybe she's not I think
that she actually I never got fake
revives from her like because she has a
butler and I don't I think if she
actually but then she's on TV so it made
me she has fake Ridge and she's selling
like caftans with dog faces on it you
should got one of the oh my god she is
it's always interesting to see what can
we pull up this picture say it's from
the trip at all chills Instagram it's
her and her friend before the gala spill
Pat ultra-chic has no idea okay oh my
god it's of her and her redheaded friend
I got time tonight but y'all chill put a
picture on her Instagram woman like
basically just like a brunette and a
redhead old lady in a picture we got
tagging it like this looks like you guys
why cuz she has red hair yeah in 50
years and you know it I look forward to
he looks great
you look great too thank you oh my god
that was so funny but what I was gonna
say it was like it's so interesting when
Bravo puts very rich people on their on
their shows because you really get to
see who has real money and who doesn't
because afterwards on social media like
the people we got the picture oh my god
that is so funny
thank you you get to see who really has
money cause like Lisa Vanderpump like
never does like teeny blends yes yes Oh
does she she's done them a few times I'm
gonna start crazy Erika Jayne never does
now she goes oh she's malnourished but
like Kyle Richards does so it makes me
like think like why is she doing 3:10
nutrition like if the biermann's do cuz
you know their whole financial thing is
like a front um but like Bethenny never
does like a fabfitfun
yeah you only get to see who of these
ladies who are all supposed to be like
at this high-class rich level who really
needs the money and who doesn't you know
for sure also this redheaded woman is
the new ambassador to Poland how crazy
so that is creepy for us like you're
gonna be in a mansion wearing the
captain and I'm gonna be the ambassador
to Poland I'm excited for you I'm
excited for you old blue poems like okay
now we need to talk about the rest of
the episode yep Katherine was the
picture of beauty and grace the only
thing she did wrong was going back for
seconds with Ashley where Ashley had the
opportunity to say they're not a family
she's just a sperm oh yeah last birth
donor an egg donor there's a sperm donor
Wow
did you need to have the talk and then
Naomi looked unbelievably beautiful the
best she's ever looks like she had her
hair teased in like a way that I need to
go get my hair done like her dress was
perfect
she looked so pretty and like I think
Craig was shipped a [ __ ] cuz he
had a date and he still wanted to go
talk to her and she was and he finally
was like saying all the things that she
wanted to hear like you were right I'm a
big piece of [ __ ] like I can't complete
anything that I start and like I make
excuses and he was ready to say all of
that and she was like Craig is finally
ready to tell me everything that I want
to hear like two years ago she but she
was like and tonight is the first time
that it doesn't matter anymore right
because she's officially over it I'm
looking at so her sad it's so sad
because like a part of me really likes
them together but I completely
understand why it didn't work out and
I'm glad that I understand that because
I feel like sometimes when shows like
well I didn't work out like Austin and
Chelsea I don't understand Maya doesn't
work out no I think in Iommi's perfect
for Craig I do not think Records Naomi
for perfect for Haley I completely agree
because it's just hard because Craig
everyone wants him to be this lawyer and
like but when he's making money selling
pillows and doing reality TV like why
would he wake up at 6:00 a.m. when he
didn't wake up at 1:00 p.m.
totally you know what I mean and that's
just like the underlying theme
throughout totally then when they can
never talk about that like you know
that's what's so annoying people are
always like ragging on Craig but what
they can't say on the show was like yo
I'm making money on Instagram and from
this show I don't need to be a lawyer
anymore right but it's not gonna suit
they're not gonna say that and I think
everyone wants me to be a lawyer because
you know this show like isn't gonna be
forever like what is he gonna do when
that time comes so I don't think it
Naomi didn't like him because he wasn't
a lawyer now it's like you need to be
thinking about our future together
because that's how I see this
relationship right no no I mean it's
something to turn off then he does want
to be a lawyer but like I totally get it
no I totally get it it's like when Andy
door from said in her book like I'm not
gonna go back to being the assistant DA
I'm making 40k a year when I can make
that on one Instagram post totally and
that's just the reality of the world we
live in but like you can never talk
about that that's like that's what we
were saying to raven like when Becca was
pointing out like how to Tia and Colt
and more like so orchestrated it's like
yes we know that but we can't say it on
the show so you sang it is just
irrelevant right like you're
orchestrated right duh she was even
friends the bad guy I have to say oh my
god and so the reunion next week looks
um amazing Naomi is with her like has a
boyfriend on the reunion so she really
doesn't give a [ __ ] what craig has to
say so I'm looking forward to it even
though like I still really like like I
just know I love Craig he's a great guy
he is right for each other um I'm coming
to terminal I'm definitely gonna tune in
to the reunion because I just want like
I want 59 minutes a non-stop Ashley well
there's gonna be three parts and she's
going to be the third part
oh she's not there for the whole thing
now oh that's annoying yeah but it's
like without her like there's not that
much to talk about like Cameron has
barely been on the show oh but I guess
Cameron does talk about being a new mom
and apologizes to Kathryn for everything
that she like how she like never really
had her back and I've been saying I love
Cameron but she's been on the wrong side
of history when it comes to Kathryn and
justice is being served for me and
that's the best feeling ever
this is such a great year for Kathryn
just like makes me sad that she to
endure so much stretch to get to 2018
for sure but you know everyone has to go
through a lot and she's she's 26 like
she's like whole like gosh you kids just
have to worry about like settling down
like she's ready to go and she's like a
mature adult ready to embark on
motherhood and she has so much time to
do it imagine like going through all
this later and like finger like oh my
god I wasted so much time yeah that's
the worst feeling like truly
yeah I feel that way like on the
weekends like on Sunday I'm like what
did I do
I didn't feel that way this weekend no
not this weekend my watch 18,000 steps
on Saturday that's so I'm like half of
them we're walking because my friends
are wild and made us go I'm like a high
Frazee walk like I think we're beggars
like we're walking to get coffee I was
like two hours later I got coffee no and
then the rest of my steps came from
Dancing cause I'm always doing the
shuffle and we were dancing hard to
shock dancing so hard so like I ate so
much this weekend I'm gonna pretend like
I don't feel bad cuz I dance and walk so
much but I feel horrible no no but but
you definitely it balances out it does
and Saturday night I did I when I wasn't
coming out like and I got ready and I
was in the car and I was like there's no
way I'm gonna not regret coming out like
I was really doing it for you because I
just didn't want to be a grandma loser
totally and your friends wanted to go
sort of I was definitely the one
grounded in the truth okay for you
because I'm a good sister you are and
just the level of fun that we had was I
couldn't even envision it you know and
I'm just so glad you know everything
happened so I should think you Chloe
traveling for the peer pressure yeah I
really needed it
um so I am here till Wednesday just some
housekeeping stuff I'm here till
Wednesday Monday Tuesday Wednesday I'm
doing a show Thursday Stephen McGee is
gonna be co-hosting the Jackie we're
gonna get all the summer house cute
because we haven't spoken to him since
he nod said he wasn't gonna be on this
season of summer house I mean the
Friday's still up in the air so that's
what we got for you I'm Claudia hi girls
I'm Jackee ashtray jackieo problem we'll
see you tomorrow
you